bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti che sono
video sono fa vj oggi siamo in un nuovo
video oggi ragazzo li parliamo di
tatuaggi molte persone nel corso della
vita vogliono farsi un tatuaggio ovvero
un segno indelebile che rimane sul corpo
molte persone hanno tatuaggio in molte
persone sono piene molte tipo tipo me ne
hanno uno due al massimo in uno che
questo qui il che mi son scassato le
palle di spiegare che cosa significa
però sorvoliamo il fatto importante
ragazzi è uno soltanto l'artista perché
fare tatuaggi è un'arte dovrà essere in
grado di disegnare bene c'è insomma di
farmi un qualche cosa che comunque
rimarrà sul corpo per sempre quindi deve
essere bravo e per darvi una
dimostrazione pratica di quello che
intendo facciamo una prova della tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono farisei ed oggi siamo su ten
cyclones tattoo non ho idea di come si
giochi n'è di che cosa tratti il gioco
ma dal titolo io ho letto questa roba ha
detto no vabbè geniale credo che lo
scopo sia quello di fare un tatuaggio in
dieci secondi che sarebbe epico i
ragazzi cimentiamo c in questa
incredibile pratica ho aspettato una
vita per fare questo tatuaggio
il tizio mi sta dicendo perché io sono
il tatuatore è allora hai fatto proprio
bene a venire da fa vj che ci pensa lui
dove lo faccio a ok già partito già
partito eccolo eccolo eccolo questo è
questo è il mio tatuaggio per te ti
piace vai da tua moglie vedi come sarà
felice e contento perfetto ragazzi
passiamo al pro ma io non ho capito
posso anche aumentare la ok
va bene a esatto bellissimo devi essere
nuovo in questo campo qualcosa te lo fa
pensare zio questo e artem immaginette
ragazzino che si fa tatuare dei baffi
che se continua di questo passo sarò io
quello a farlo perché non mi crescono
aspettando questo da sempre va bene se
io ci penso io e adesso hai una collana
da gangster finta e se contento io avrei
paura per la tua vita sempre più sicuro
zio perché questo è un capolavoro cioè
sei tu che non capisci
allora ragazzi a questo punto direi di
provare a imitare dei tatuaggi veramente
esistenti questo qua è bello è un albero
con delle rondini dobbiamo imitare
questa cosa dai via ok bene perfetto le
rondini rondini però un dinho
dimenticare lo so zio se sei incazzato
perché ho dimenticato le rom in te le
rifaccio teneri faccio ok
ecco le rondini perfetto
adesso se adesso sei a posto alle parate
adesso è bello prima non lo era però
adesso è figo altro dato a questo questo
è veramente figura laribi laribi
ricordarmi ragazzi la cosa più
importante la scritta alleri bibbia
madonna madonna capello è bellissimo 20
mila libri pt no la e cazzola ho
dimenticato la e vabbè dai c'era
se non era per lei alla fine c'era
abbiamo ecco fedez sarebbe il massimo
della vita riuscirà a fare questo in
dieci secondi ragazzi miei raiders so
che sarei fiero di me dopo questo sono
convintissimo desco non cambia colore
pure ci manca solo quella eccolo bene
perfetto ho fatto fede questo è molto
più corso dipinto è fede più o meno è
già sim ibert justin bieber justin
bieber ha la croce sul petto ea va bene
devo fare questa roba in dieci secondi
va bene la scritta non allora 1975 1975
una corona è una croce va bene vai dei
pronto justin pesca
bellissima la corona perfetto con la
1975 la colonna veloce perfetto justin
bieber ce l'ha fatta ragazzi cellophane
e lui e justin non potevo farlo meglio
di così ragazze ora sei pronto per
uscire fratello sembra gotti e come si
pronuncia non lo so
cosa posso fare a fare quello di mike
tyson più o meno stato mike tyson coi
capelli lunghi e inguardabile perfetto
benissimo credo più o meno giusto ma è
giusto ovviamente cercando taylor swift
da tu invece di trovare dei tatuaggi di
taylor swift
ho trovato il tailor swift come
tatuaggio allora taylor punti chiave
capelli biondi occhi azzurri è una [ __ ]
della madonna quindi non possono anche
fare il biondo quindi partiamo mai
facciamo rosso ci avrà avuto un periodo
di rosso che nei suoi occhi azzuri
c'abbiamo manca il biondo però vabbè dai
ok perfetto e gli occhi sono questi qua
perfetto il naso tutto il resto viper fi
grandissimo taylor a punto chiave del
biondo è andato a [ __ ] prova bel
altro era negli occhi azzurri gli occhi
azzurri ci sono quindi quelli non si può
dire il terzo punto chiave che una [ __ ]
della madonna e beh ma volendo una
bottarella per come contento lui sei
contento di taylor swift tatuata addosso
va bene alla spinta cita le imprese
bello bellissimo
proviamoci ragazzi i colori ce li
abbiamo quasi tutti tranne il giallo
effettivamente provato
olè che bella faccia sa tipo ehi prof
mio ragazzi se riesco e non lo so perché
oddio mi ricordo neanche bene come ha
fatto pensate come cazzo sto messo devo
tenere braccio così lo faccio con la
sinistra lo faccio con la sinistra sono
pronto e non so neanche arrivare al
mouse con la sinistra bello uguale ed è
proprio lui
dai più o meno più o meno dai pensavo
molto peggio giuro lo ying e lo yang che
non so mica è il cert no vabbè ma mi è
venuto da ridere quando ho fatto il
cerchio c'è il cerchio e meraviglioso è
il cerchio più ovale che abbia mai fatto
in tutta la mia vita perfetto per tutto
nero ma né un pezzettino che dava offre
dai dai dai se lo si guarda bene invece
che lo ingoia mi sembra un una papera e
una papera incazzata non so perché ieri
questa è la è il tatuaggio migliore che
non si potrebbe mai fare nella vita
perfetto ragazzino io io io vorrei
soltanto dirvi ha intenzione di
rovinarmi la vita ma sei scemo con un
tatuaggio del genere giva pretto nudo
come niente zeman sei veramente stupido
pedrazzi co
porca [ __ ] sta facendo pikachu
bellissimo beh c'è pensavo molto peggio
bello questo mi piace cazzo a me
piacciono i ragni quindi lo faccio molto
bene dai proviamoci
ecco più o meno non è non è malissimo
allora ragazzi a dire che possono
chiudere l'episodio è stata è stato
troppo figo il concept del gioco è
veramente figo il fatto è che i 10
secondi sono un po pochi però va bene
nel genere senso se tv fa ste cose va
bene però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi un
bel laica lasciate un bel like anche
dopo questo ecco questo è il tasto
dell'aiff perfetto adesso quest'uomo
andrà in giro per le città del mondo a
petto nudo per farmi lasciare i like sui
video ma c'è al momento mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook e come video
tonale descrizione se ne saresti di sky
ci vediamo al prossimo video lasciato il
telecomando a casa però posto da to
heart e lo posso tatuarsi che sono a
casa in realtà prove ecco questo è il
telecomando
il caso ami hour anche in 3d chi è
sembra un sandwich ma ve ragazzi sono
stati avvertiti scalatrici mediano
prossimo vi è un prossimo tatuaggio
fatto molto meglio
beh ragazzi qua ho perso il pezzo dietro
il telecomando e per non far cadere le
pile
ho messo lo scotch quindi è mi sono
dimenticato di tattoo arti lo scotch zio
va bè ragazzi